I had the most depressing thing happen
to me I was playing and I like to do
this thing if our team is losing I like
to say I'm 33 I got this okay
okay like relinquish like control yeah
and judgment are they like oh you're the
leader now
um no no I mean it like because in
OverWatch you pick a role so I I just I
only know how to play like shooting
roles so like DPS so I'll say that as
sort of implies like I'm gonna go out
there and get like 50 kills okay yeah
um but obviously I'm not because I'm 33
right and I had some kid go wait you're
33. I go yep 33 and then uh we were
about to win and he's like are you
actually 33 I said yep he's like man
you're pretty cool for 30 years
you're like how old are you he's like
I'm three